let's get to living space because this
this this is important too
this is important too and it's going to
circle back you're going to see that
circling back to the car
but this is important let's take a look
um
Place matters I think cleanliness
matters the most like it doesn't have to
be well decorated or well furnished or
anything I mean at least like have a
couch and maybe some kitchen utensils
but cleanliness like tops all of the
factors I think obviously a space where
a person lives is a big indication of
how
they treat themselves and they respect
themselves so if it's clean if it's well
put together then that means that you're
you're kind of like your mind is
decluttered but if it's cluttered then
it's just like speaks volumes to
the kind of person you are
um
yeah so a clean space is a nice space it
doesn't matter if it's big or small
um I like when guys keep it clean
um dishes are done fresh towels
I feel like putting the seat down
cleaning the bathroom yeah when I walk
into your space if it's just totally
trashed I feel
uncomfortable so which is funny because
I have clothes all over my room all the
time but it's really just like the trash
and things piling up that I'm like
and please like wash your sheets like
once a week or
I don't know it depends location maybe
not so much but like overall tidiness of
the home I definitely don't want to walk
into something that looks like a smelly
bachelor pad
um but I mean it just depends on how you
keep your place
architect or like the building itself
doesn't matter but the architecture is
it decorated does it smell good yeah it
definitely matters because I want to be
somewhere that's comfortable
and like a safe area like definitely I
feel like when you walk into someone's
apartment like the first thing is the
smell make sure it smells clean like
take out the trash do your dishes like
just basic wash the floors
um
I feel like that's like a good as long
as it smells good and it's clean and
like I really like minimal like you
don't have a bunch of junk everywhere
and trash like I accept totally accept
the Pokemon cards but like put them in a
drawer okay so the question is do you
believe them right the part about
cleanliness yes that's true a trick will
size up a space and if she sees all dust
and nastiness going on Dish is piled up
and if it smells dirty you know the
smell you know that bachelor pad like
college dorm smell
yeah that's bad but do you think that
they're being honest when they say I
don't care if a Spiller big or small you
know just have a couch I don't care I
don't know because if you're
simultaneously saying you want that guy
to be earning six figures you're gonna
have expectations about that home
you know six figures comes with you know
you've got the car that goes with the
six figure salary you've got the place I
don't know I don't know if there's
enough self-awareness here for them to
connect the dots of like if you're
saying this
it also trickles out to this so if
you're saying 100K if you're saying 400k
that world that said 400 000 you can't
tell me you're not going to be sizing up
that pad when she's going to be going in
with one of those things the blood what
is those lights that you put on the bed
and see the UV lights yeah yeah you know
when you go on a hotel you see all that
grime
um don't do that you'll never stay in
hotel Again by the way but it ain't
Grime you're seeing what is it actually
it's some nasty stuff Tyler don't even I
won't because I'm already to the point
of where I'm like huh even if I need to
fly there I ain't going airplanes nasty
anyway you know she's gonna be going in
with those lights you know
looking around making sure the furniture
is up to par 400 000 a year she's gonna
expect to walk in to some apartment come
on so just be honest like own it just be
like yeah I want a big ass house you
know I want this or I want it just
doesn't align oh I don't care about your
house just make your 400 what do you
think he's doing with 400 000 You're
Gonna Want That manifested in spaces you
share don't lie don't lie
so also
Pro tip this is one thing that will be a
deal breaker
and I know this doesn't happen a lot in
the country but it happens a lot in the
cities if you're 30 years old and you've
got a bunch of roommates
and you invite a girl back and you're a
grown ass man now you have a job you
have all that and they walk in and they
it looks like a dorm and it's like oh
there's Bobby in his room in the rooms
you know it's like oh a room here she's
out she's out you can get away with that
in your early 20s everybody understands
you come out of college and you're kind
of like doing the the partial adult life
you're it's the transition right between
college life and adult life
once you hit 30 come on you can't be you
can't be living like that you are better
by the way to get a smaller space get a
studio apartment live on your own and
keep that man you know well manicured
and clean than to be living with a bunch
of people because you know what she
doesn't grown as woman she don't want to
come over there and be around a bunch of
kids and then they're friends and then
like oh it's party time all the time and
then she's got to walk to the bathroom
at night but she's like uh I gotta put a
bra on to go to the bed you know they
don't no that's all uncomfortable
that's okay for post College it's not
okay for adulthood if you want to watch
the full episode you're going to click
right here and if you want to ask me a
question one on one you want to do a
one-on-one FaceTime with a group of your
friends whatever you want you need to
download right now click right here and
let's get talking
foreign
[Music]